brittany is with us in
ann arbor hi brittany welcome to the
dave ramsey show
hi there dave hi dr john how are you
great how can we help
so i grew up in a really really poor
family
and i married into a family who's super
good with money
um since my husband and i got married we
paid off 58 000 in our debt but we still
have 36
000 to go good um
my parents keep asking us for money
though because we had been open and
honest at the beginning that we were
doing the dave ramsey plan
because we were hoping that they would
follow along too
but they think now that because we've
paid off so much that we have a lot more
money in our month to work with
and now they're asking for money and
making me feel bad about not helping
them
i don't intend to help them and i told
them no and we've laid down that
boundary but they keep asking and in
private i feel really bad
how do i deal with the feelings of shame
from my parents
why do you feel bad because i feel like
i'm letting them down
so beyond the feel one of the things i
tell people all the time is to
demand evidence from your feelings is
that a true statement are you letting
down your parents
i don't know no you know you like
they're grown-ups who are choosing not
yeah like they should know how to deal
with this
but they weren't taught how to deal with
their money either
and they don't want to take from me
saying that we should do dave ramsey
together because
they're they're my parents and so
they're thinking like what the heck does
she know
and so you're good enough to give them
money but not good enough to give them
advice well that's an interesting
arrogance that's right
so i will help you with your with your
with your algebraic equation
demanding evidence does a plus b equal c
in this one
no your parents are making a grown-up
decision to do grown-up things with
their money
and they're making a childish immature
decision to hit their child up for money
because they
can't be disciplined themselves you were
released from that
you're doing a hard wise adult thing and
you're setting up boundaries for
yourself and your family
you've done a hard thing which is to
communicate those to your parents
and those are the hardest and then
they're going to keep
banging their head up against those
boundaries to see if they hold and let
me tell you
just i'll just say out loud okay this is
papa dave
all right the fact that they even ask
you for money
is wrong
that's wrong thank you this is wrong
they don't have rights to your money
the fact that they put you in that
corner and make you feel that way is
just wrong
it's just wrong and um it's child abuse
it's adult child abuse and um
you know there's something in their
upbringing that makes them think that
it's okay
well we're all family that's why we say
when we're hillbillies right
we're all family and that that means
you're supposed to put up with toxic
bull crap
that's what that phrase means we're all
family which right
that that means you're supposed to
tolerate stupidity
and just embrace it because it's part or
we're family
nope nope nope you're crazy
because you're building a new family
right a new legacy
you're you're ending that nonsense with
you and
here we talk about boundaries a lot and
we also talk about it the the
the the cycle stop with you and when
they talk about it in
in therapeutic sessions they talk about
a raging forest fire that someone
finally stops and turns and
faces down what they don't tell about
that metaphor is that when you stop and
face down a forest fire you get burned
it hurts
and that's where you are right now it
sucks it's hard yeah
and your kids are not gonna have to deal
with this nonsense because you took one
for the legacy you took one for the
family tree you're changing the family
tree
and it hurts but you're doing right so
the only way you can
uh have these discussions anymore is
just say
a we're not gonna have any more
discussions about this mom and dad
the answers are perpetual no
no or okay or
if you want to help after you're out of
your baby step two you can't help at all
while you're in baby step two you're not
allowed i'm not gonna let you
okay don't tell me dave said you suck
no okay so no don't tell him that but
just tell him dave said no
and so um but the uh
once you have some money but right now
you're broken in debt
okay so you don't have any money so we
don't need to talk about you being
outrageously generous to somebody i mean
you'd be tithing if you're a christian
or whatever but that that's you know but
giving money away to
in to enable relatives is not it's not
even on your list right now you're
trying to get out of debt
get your emergency fund but once you're
in baby step four if you want to reach
over
and pay a 500 bill or something that
has to come if it's coming from my house
here's what it would sound like to a
friend or a family member
i'm gonna give you a gift of five
hundred dollars
one time on the condition that
you complete financial peace university
and if you're unwilling to go to the
class and complete that
then i'm unwilling to make you the gift
because i am not going to give a cocaine
addict
money for their cocaine and you when it
comes to money are a cocaine addict you
are misbehaving
and you have for decades
and i love you enough to tell you that
and when you quit misbehaving i will
fund your recovery
i will not fund your misbehavior because
that's called enabling
enablers are sweet people but they do
not help
they actually harm when you give a drunk
a drink
you are actually causing them to be a
drunk
you're not blessing them
that's why we were saying no yes you're
really not helping so every day
yeah you're really not helping and it's
just so hard now i will tell you this
too
what john says true the forest fire is
going to burn
this is going to hurt and it's not
going to quit hurting i'm not going to
tell you that here's why
your spiritual dna is designed
to want to please your heavenly father
that same connective tissue is the
connective tissue
you have to your mom and dad and so your
desire to please them
will not go away as long as you breathe
the problem is that while you try desire
to please god he is perfect in his love
towards you
they are imperfect in their love towards
you and so you have to set up boundaries
but you're not going to get away from
the desire to please your parents as
long as you breathe
even after they're dead some people
spend half their
60s and 70s trying to please dead
parents
trying to live up to my daddy's
expectations and he's been gone for
20 years and that kind of a thing so
your desire to please your parents is
built into your spiritual dna
you're not going to get away from that
and that's why it hurts that's why it
hurts but you got to give your
and so what dave is saying you got to
give yourself some space when those
feelings come they're real
you acknowledge them and then you demand
evidence and then you realize
no i'm doing the right thing yeah and
then you can go about your day
yeah my my desire to please my dad is a
natural thing my desire to please my mom
is a natural thing
their request is unnatural and toxic
and wrong and morally wrong and so i
that's where you have to separate it and
there's some there's some people dave
that prey on that
well they do they're called travel agent
for guilt trips right right they prey on
that
on that desire to please yep right yep
yeah they know and they know how to
manipulate it oh yeah
how to play it and so and again
sometimes it's a cultural thing it's
like
i i i can hear it not my family didn't
do this but i've heard it in the
neighborhood the hillbilly elegy that i
grew up in kind of a thing and it's just
like
well you know it's family and you got to
take care of family
regardless of how stupid and out of
control and toxic they are i have to
take care of them
well maybe not maybe he needs to stay in
jail a while he drinks every weekend and
beats his wife it's a good idea for him
to stay there i don't care if he's
family you know i mean maybe the
the best way to help out right yeah
that's what he needs to be incarcerated
this guy needs to be off the street he
happens to be my brother but you know
it's like
that's not my case but i mean i've
watched this kind of stuff my whole life
and it's like well they're family that
doesn't matter
it means you overlook complete disasters
no we don't overlook it we love them in
spite of that
but that doesn't mean we're going to
embrace the stupidity and
endorse it and make it a part of our the
rhythm of our life and the rhythm of our
children's lives as a result and
you got to break the cycle not even the
rhythm it's it's the
the soul and integrity and strength of
your family and your marriage and your
kids and wherever you're headed right
and the netflix movie i think sucks but
the book was
one of the best books i've ever read a
hillbilly elegy about jetty vance it's
extraordinary and it's extraordinary
book
and um the uh because the
book itself talks about how he broke the
cycle he gave honor to his upbringing
and yet broke the cycle and both those
things were accomplished beautifully not
in the screenplay
but in the book